jordan montgomery on the season this
will be his 25th start
the numbers are very good across the
board there's a lot to like here's the
payoff
stuck him out swinging 2a
classic look in a classic pitch the
montgomery changeup
grounded durizo wide of the bag and he
will beat
hayes to the bag they'll take their
swings off the 28 year old right-hander
chris ellis chris ellis born in
birmingham alabama drafted by the angels
in the third round back in 2014 judged
with the lead at second
stanton line drive center field mullins
on the move makes the catch to end the
inning
3-2
montgomery's going to win that battle
as rizzo makes the play hitting 321
since coming over the orioles
and that one is popped up
two-way
[Applause]
high fly ball
gardner
puts it away and montgomery works into
and out of trouble no runs two hits
and two men left on base we'll go to the
bottom of the second
this year the raise in the oats the next
pitch foul tip strike three
so brandon heidi talked about the curve
ball but so far ellis has shown a really
nice slider through these first two
innings and he earns his first strikeout
of anthony rosa
you got to go right after velasquez here
3-2
line drive caught by jones the second
baseman going to his left he snow coned
it
and takes the hit away from andrew
velasquez
montgomery's 2-2 strike three is a
breaking ball strike on the inside one
away
second strikeout for monty
here's the o2
hit on the ground again to backhanded by
lemayo from his knees close to first in
time beautiful play by dj the ball was
hit between velasquez and dj on the
right side dj made a sliding backhand
stop where he couldn't get up because
mullins would be safe so he threw from
his knees
soft ground ball to short charging
velasquez
and a one two three inning for
montgomery retired six in a row and
we'll go to the bottom of the third
rookie if you will by the standards of
baseball wade bunts it back to the mound
off the mound is ellis he gloves it and
flips to first to complete the out well
done chris ellis he had to go a long way
to field that tyler wade bunt and in one
motion gloved the baseball and then
flipped it to mount castle at first
let's see if he goes back to the change
up here the one-two pitch
swing and a miss he blew a fastball by
him gallows strikes out and chris ellis
is through three in the bronx
mateo popped out to second base his only
at-bat of the day that came in the
second inning full cop pitch coming
and the dirt ball four gets away and
mancini will score orioles on the board
it trickles away again and montgomery
picks it up now the orioles have a
one-nothing lead so a walk and a wild
pitch and the birds are on the board
yeah a lot of high fives of the oriole
dugout oils will take runs right now any
way they can get them here's mount
castle long set by montgomery the o2
that's a big strikeout of a tough hitter
one away after all those signs
this pitch works three inherited runners
from jordan montgomery the big stat for
a relief pitcher holmes now up 0-2
straight three maurice down on strikes
so he was handled handed the will and as
any good executor did
he took care of business
strikes out urius and three men stranded
so two walks by ellis here in the fifth
inning putting runners on first and
second and bringing up dj lemayo
runners moving full count on the way
fly ball popped up short right field
jones is there and he's got it big time
effort
no hit no run ball for five
now top of the order the base hit his
last at bat
that'll work base hit into right field
jones around third he will score cedric
mullins slides in with a double and the
orioles are on top two nothing rbi
number 50 for cedric back-to-back
doubles well i love that approach by
cedric
mullins grounded up the middle oh what a
play by velasquez throw to first and the
scoop by rizzo moving to third is
mullins but velasquez just saved a run
it was a hot shot going up the middle
velasquez made a diving stop got to his
feet and through
just nip mount castle going to third was
mullins of course two nothing baltimore
to run in the pitch shot back to the
mound off the mouse peralta mullins
coming home flip throw to the plate buds
is safe he beat the tag from the catcher
kyle higashioka and it's three nothing
orioles wandy peralta did all he could
and cedric mullins flying to home plate
beat the flip throw and it's going to be
glad torres pinch hitting for andrew
velasquez parker does not go and that's
grounded up the middle
bubble
and everybody is safe a run scores the
yankees on the board it's three to one
that should be a hit we'll see how they
score it but the yankees are on the
board runners on first and second one
out and it is a base hit for torrez and
an rbi
boy's a pretty good pinch hitter 298 in
his career
could be two
to second for one on to first and a
great great scoop from mount castle on
the back hand side the orioles turn two
well if you believe in dude joey gallo
is due he's over his last 17 three for
his last 30. here's the one two
swung on and line to right field and
it's going high it is far it is gone to
tie the game
joey jackson into the right field seats
hey he's pal joey a two-run home run to
tie the ball game
and we're all knotted at three maurice
with a single and a walk in this game
the 2-2
strike three got him on the outside
corner with a fastball one away here's
pedro struck out looking his last two at
bats doubled in the fourth inning 3-2
left field it should get a run home
gallow waits makes the grab
his throw comes to the infield and the
orioles have the lead severino with a
fly ball sacrifice rbi
for three orioles
big time at bat by pedro severino
and the pitch swinging and miss got him
but not before the orioles take the lead
cole salser will try to slam the door
shut
2-2 on the way and he got him ball game
down on strikes
cole salser closes it out and gets the
win the orioles
with a 4-3 victory today some great
pitching starting with chris ellis